okay um
first draw of the match i guess that's
fine
let's go bishop e5 play more closed
positions against him
knight d7 all right
what's his idea here
i had a game against jeffrey drawing in
this line
where i got a very good position as
white
i should have yeah i should have studied
the line since but i
i haven't unfortunately oh this is the
way that they play
yeah have this against somebody
get scary maybe okay let's go rook to
one
yeah the wide scores are
from games were played before but two
and a half two and a half
that's the that's the score right now
and if i'm lucky i have one or
maybe even two mods and they will
be able to to bring updates
if needed
two mods certainly would be a personal
or
no sorry three mods certainly would be a
personal record for me
okay
go start going e5 knight d5 c4
yeah let's just do that simplify the
game a little bit
du5 then i should be somewhat better
just because 98 well
okay before
now yeah it seems a bit
excessive to me yeah asia's is not here
today so the fridge is not a problem
now i've waited with the development of
this knight to get it to its most active
square
now that the pawn on c3 is gone
and generally
generally um i feel like i'm a bit
better here now
okay let's try and get active on the
king side
um
i guess 94 94
d5 d5 you can connect sorry to queen b5
maybe
ugh back to the scuffed arrows now
that's a bit annoying maybe i could
could have played this better
what to do
oh i don't actually have anything at all
here
would be a bit disappointing okay
can't think anymore
i need to take action
bishop is awful in g3 though
so at least the supporting knight comes
to d6 so i guess that's something
now he went with the knight from c7
which means that queen b5 is never an
option
i feel like that's favorable to me
yeah let's
gotta speed up
d4 routine one seems like a good plan
the old centralization when they don't
know what to do
also the rook could swing over here
after this light has moved somewhere
okay
now let's jump in
knight c8
didn't expect this to be any good
maybe i don't have anything here
okay let's go back
i'm just throwing pieces at him
literally not even caring
yeah this probably didn't work i wanted
knight f6 but he has
rook c4 now it's
massively annoying
otherwise i think this would work
this one huh can't i jump in now
knight f6 i still got gf6 and rook d4
rook d4
don't think this check is any dangerous
and i retain all my
attacking potential on the king side
rooksy one first
look at this works
yeah i don't have time rook d1 rook h4
now this mating though isn't it
jack oh he's going to h6
take the bishop where's the okay i think
i have a pretty clean win
bishop h4 and then bishop f6
we should have tried the h5 first maybe
now this wins easily rook fade knight c7
and i just start advancing the king
yeah well